american politics depends on competition
between two parties
the republicans and the democrats but
after
four years led by donald trump the
republicans find themselves
out of power in the white house and in
the u.s
congress the republicans rejoice in
being the party of abraham lincoln
and donald trump has often compared
himself favorably
to the great defender of democracy and
justice
but even some in his own party now think
trump has made a mockery of those ideals
the the rock went deep and the
corruption of trumpism
the step-by-step sort of willingness to
tolerate well a little bit of lying a
little bit of demagoguery does it really
matter well i had a president for four
years just
hammering away at that and a party a
republican party
uh rationalizing and enabling that and
that combination i think has done
has done damage which isn't going to go
away in a week or a month every year
far from being the president of law and
order the american carnage trump incited
has left his successor being inaugurated
in a virtual state of siege
the degree of mayhem unleashed and the
lack of respect for political norms
is underlined by the fact that a
national manhunt is now underway
for the protester who laid a powerful
pipe bomb here
at republican party headquarters on the
day that donald trump
jr told the crowd it was now
trump's republican party in spite of
what happened
a new generation of trump loyalists in
congress
were vehement in his support during the
impeachment debate
where's the accountability for the left
after encouraging
and normalizing violence rather than
actually helping
american people in this time we start
impeachments
that further divide our country i call
bullcrap some have cited the metaphor
that the president lit the flame
will they lit actual flames actual
fires
but can trump loyalists be reconciled
with people like
the 10 republican members of congress
who voted to impeach him
i think it would be a mistake to look at
donald trump's supporters as a block of
grant
unmovable unchangeable always loyal to
him
i would say this that i think many
commentators
have overlooked at noon on the 20th of
january
trump goes from sitting in the most
powerful office in the world the oval
office
to sitting by the pool at mar-a-lago and
it will never be the same again
normally the inauguration parade would
march down pennsylvania avenue
instead barricades are going up to keep
the public out
the hotel trump set up boastfully a
block from the white house
is all but empty and up for sale a
potent symbol of dashed hopes
so is it the end of trump on the
national stage
omarosa manigault newman who stuck by
trump
from the apprentice tv show to the white
house before quitting and branding him
unhinged certainly hope so well we know
that
75 74 75 million people supported donald
trump
but in terms of their view i think it's
changing the numbers have already shown
that he is losing support from his base
his key base
the most loyal base who has never
deserted him in the last five years
and so that should be concerning for
donald but more importantly
it shows that americans have had enough
donald trump is holed up in the white
house for his last few days behind
makeshift
barricades not saying much because
twitter
have cut his megaphone the question
for president biden is how large donald
trump's voice will be
in the republican party once he's gone